laughs as infectious
that is Chewbacca mom and by now you
have probably seen this viral video I
mean who hasn't 136 million views and
Counting now on Thursday
Candace Payne was a housewife waiting
for her kids having a little bit of fun
on Facebook and and one weekend
she has become internationally famous so
our senior news producer Jennifer
Pharaohs met up with Candace today on
her way to James Corden in Hollywood to
find out how it feels to be an instant
star I can't fake the laughs is worth
every the force was strong with Candace
when she went all wookie last Thursday
you probably seen the video by now
okay okay I just wanted to tell
everybody this is mine
I made a purchase for my birthday for
myself now I may not get to keep it but
I'm gonna enjoy it
Cheers Oh yep that total joy and
contagious laugh has this Texas mom
headed to a galaxy far far away that's
right she's going to Hollywood she did
GMA this morning and then hopped on a
plane to LA for her appearance on James
Corden tonight I had to tell somebody
yeah I've got to be at hair and makeup I
don't even know what that means you know
what I mean that's hysterical in and of
itself
you actually came here to New York stop
a couple years ago I know where you're
going
new magicians for the voice I auditioned
for the voice I made it to the second
round
yes and then I didn't get a callback so
what did Candace is two kids think of
her newfound fame my daughter's class
watched it in class on Friday and then
she told me when she got home mom I'm
popular because of you and I just start
laughing on her I was like okay we're
gonna bring down that in just a couple
seconds okay you all have an incredible
day it's a simple joke all the note the
sound of a shoe laughter she's got the
best thing out of all of this was
getting people to laugh and smile I
agree with all of that and I cannot wait
to see her on James corn tonight she
seems like a hoot
no ads a lot of fun watch the video just
over and over